You may not think of spiders as the maternal sort.
But some do make good moms.
Wolf spiders carry their egg sacs around.
And after hatching, the spiderlings ride on mom’s back.
This ant-mimicking jumping spider takes another tack—
she provides milk to her babies.
At first, they suck up little droplets that
the mother places around the nest.
As they get larger, the spiderlings suckle
straight from their mom’s epigastric furrow.
In lab tests, researchers found they continued to suckle
until the spiders became subadults—
which is about 40 days after hatching.
Researchers were able to figure this out
by carefully watching these families in their nests.
Even though the mother spider never brought
anything back to the nest to eat, the spiderlings
tripled in length in the first 20 days.
To look more closely at the benefit of this
milk and maternal care, the researchers painted
over the mom’s epigastric furrow
to cut off the milk supply.
Without milk, they found that the young didn’t grow
and died about 10 days later.
When they removed the mother after 20 days,
the subadults foraged on their own--
more than they would if mom were there but
fewer survived over all.
What is spider milk anyway?
The milk comes out of this egg-laying opening
the spiders have--so one idea is that the
spider milk might be evolutionarily
related to trophic eggs.
This is when animals feed infertile eggs
to their offspring.
Spider milk is protein rich.
An analysis of the milk droplets revealed
the protein content was around 4 times
that of cow’s milk
While it is not usual for animals, even invertebrates
like spiders and cockroaches, to give their
food to their young--the length and intensity
of feeding and maternal care given by
these jumping spider moms was thought to only happen
in cognitively advanced, social vertebrates,
like orangutans, people, and and elephants.
Researchers speculate that if there’s a
chance
there will be no food for newborns,
or all the young spiders are very likely to get
eaten by predators, then it can make sense
for a mother to take on the cost of parental care.
This milk-giving spider suggests scientists
will need to rethink the extent of maternal
care and milk provisioning
throughout the animal kingdom
And how much cognitive power you need
to take care of offspring in these ways.